today is the deadline for contractors to
finish their prototype for president
Trump's proposed southern border wall
all eight are already complete in a
remote section of San Diego the Trump
administration asked Congress for 1.6
billion dollars in financing to start
the new wall it is not approved yet
Mireya virial is in San Diego along the
two existing walls at the us-mexico
border today a good morning well good
morning a lot of the original wall which
is what you see up on that hill past
this secondary wall is built from
Vietnam era material it's about 10 to 18
feet in most places and it pales in
comparison in size and technology when
you're looking at the new prototypes
space 30 feet apart and costing up to
$500,000 each these eight models offer
just a glimpse of president Trump's
proposed border wall with Mexico look
closer and you'll see variations in
design color and construction for our
solid concrete four others are made of
concrete and a combination of materials
like steel
each of these prototypes is about 30
feet high but what you don't see is
what's buried beneath all of this
concrete and metal there is technology
that goes down nearly 40 feet to stop
from tunneling which is a big problem
here in the San Diego area I think each
one has its own characteristics
Mario Gabriel is the San Diego division
chief for the US Customs and Border
Protection we don't have to select just
one we can identify key characteristics
from one and maybe another that we can
use towards the future there are critics
that will say that this is destruction
politics that right now there isn't any
sort of money to make this whole wall
once you even decide on a prototype
everywhere where I have worked where
we've put up tactical infrastructure
it has work for us this border wall and
those prototypes are monuments to fear
Pedro Rios the director for the American
Friends Service Committee disagrees
we're not really dealing with
immigration the way we should be these
border prototype walls aren't doing
anything to resolve the issue
six construction companies from five
states were selected from hundreds of
bidders a selection process Michael
Evangelista a saga says was rushed to
meet deadlines we all said look you know
just a lot of red flags his construction
company built this small sample wall
that took an expert welder two hours and
four minutes to cut through more than
double the time requested by the
government but border patrol dismissed
his company's proposals because of
incomplete paperwork he claims was
misguided from the start to put this
thing out on the street and say there's
a 10 page limit and there's a limited
window within which to submit your
design ideas really was so far off the
reservation that we really didn't quite
know what to do with it the Border
Patrol will actually be testing this
agents with the Border Patrol will be
testing this along with private citizens
over the next few months
basically what they will be doing is
checking out this a scale and size to
see how difficult it could be to breach
these prototypes that process will begin
at the end of November all right got it
Thank You Maria